I have some new tour dates to announce
uh I will be in Springdale Utah on July
6th at the OC Tanner Amphitheater I'm
excited to get out there and spend some
time with my brother and uh and with you
guys uh so you can grab those tickets
pre-sale is live now with the code Rat
King General on sale begins Friday March
10th at 10 A.M local time as well uh
next week we will be going on sale with
tickets for Toronto we've also added a
fourth Show in Las Vegas Nevada on July
1st at The Encore Theater
um as well we have tickets remaining for
Uncasville Connecticut on July 21st at
the Mohegan
Sun Arena and Atlantic City New Jersey
on Sunday July 23rd at the Hard Rock
Live at etes Arena
um at Hard Rock show it will be a little
bit of a bigger venue than usual but we
will have screens in there
um which I'm actually very excited about
uh having that experience myself get
your tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r and thank you so much
um I can't thank you enough uh for
coming out the show is awesome so I hope
to see you there
today's guest is a content creator
um I checked out some of his stuff
recently and I got absolutely lost in
his world uh he is
he is unique and I'm grateful that he's
here today
um today's guest is funny Marco
[Music]
and
I always
[Applause]
something guys aren't really available a
lot of the black minions tour a lot so
we get to see him in town as much yeah
and then JB Smoove said he would come on
but
he doesn't come on yet no they're gonna
see work they're gonna see sometimes
people miss the train and it's like bro
it was here waiting yeah it's gonna take
off oh this is my damn Hogwarts bro
we've been [__] serving pork out of
this business for a while you know
um but you you've had a podcast of your
own yeah yeah I I would say like
I call it like a Awkward TV show and I
[__] with uh how you say his name Kayla
Preston yeah Casey and me and him be
talking I really like it so I do
actually look up to his [__] and before
like it just kind of like I had the
awkward comedy and then like I love this
awkward interviews and then I obviously
do it on the street so I was just like
you know what I'm saying let's just do
it and then like it's kind of like where
it's such thing as like the black
culture and I'm like we don't have that
in ours you know what I'm saying so uh
so tell me a little more oh you don't
have that kind of awkward in here yes
yes oh interesting we don't so I was
like and I look up to him which I'm
saying shout out to him yeah he's good
yeah he's good and then it was just kind
of dope and it's just kind of like with
watching and what I tell people is we
rolling Amy yeah yeah okay what I tell
people is sometimes with content you got
to watch and do your homework who's
great you know what I'm saying yeah like
Kobe Bryant watching Michael Jordan yeah
to get to appropriate like just imagine
him like no I don't want to be like him
like and he give him his props nowadays
people don't get props like actually I
watch your show and they're like damn
it's some more [__] that you made me
inspire me to do more stand up oh really
yeah oh wow man thanks dude yeah you
don't give a [__] when you're on stage
yeah I don't well I just want to be I
want to be able to be who I I want to be
able to say whatever I want to say you
know and I feel like you can't sometimes
yeah and the whole reason I got into
this business because I just felt like I
the only thing I had was my voice you
know it's like I didn't have anything
else growing up so it was like all I had
was my voice so I wanted to be able to
say whatever I wanted to say but then
you start to run the risk of people
getting upset or if you know but I I
want to run that risk you know it's like
you want to be able to you want to be
able to have some risks our favorite
comedian said this is not therapy this
is a place where you come and laugh if
you want to be put your feelings and
[__] go to [__] therapy yeah don't
come you go to a comedy club to [__]
laugh not to be like why he say that
yeah at the end of the day is this funny
are you gonna relate to it or not that
is what it is my thing is it's gonna hit
for people that's that can relate to it
funny and it's not funny but when you
try to pick out what I say now you're
going too [__] far
right right it's like your closet so
imagine somebody coming to your closet
and telling you why the [__] you got
this shirt this what the [__] shirt I
got I want this shirt if you don't like
it don't [__] like it but don't come
in here and try to pick out what the
[__] is in my closet so comedy is in
your closet and people step into your
room right and it's like either you like
what's in my closet or you don't
yeah I think the tricky part gets is
like well I'm noticed two things for one
I noticed sometimes I uh I'll do the
same thing I start falling into the same
trap where I will be sensitive about
[__] sometimes so I gotta watch it I'll
notice it you know it's like because
some of that is a trap that's kind of
been created out there I think social
media Twitter did it a lot you know with
everybody seeing everything and then
realizing no you can just say whatever
you want to things and you should be
sensitive about stuff so I noticed that
yeah I hate that [__] and then also
sometimes I gotta be careful because I
almost if my mood isn't good I'll let
myself lean in there a little bit you
know
um dude you're [__] [__] bro it's
so good now you are you got titties dude
we're not do I have what no what'd you
say
um
let me think about it oh when you
bro when you're asking those people if
they had too many plates oh yeah I
believe at the Golden Corral I kind of I
look unbelievable yeah it was kind of
like it's like you're a traffic guard
for [__] [__] right okay so
basically the manager had noticed that
you've been in here you've been eating
too many plates no that's not true okay
so how many plates have you ate and
people fall for it and that's why I tell
people it's like a mindset thing like
this guy right here that they showing oh
this is every dude and ever since I've
seen I've seen this dude a million
you're like Stifler right in my life
yeah yeah bro
and I say it was like I gotta get him
for some reason he had a gun on them too
yeah he patted like that whole time he
was just like he was like tell him come
holla at me I'm like yeah that was the
last dude I was like let's get the [__]
out of here tell him to come and talk to
me we'll be good I'll be sitting right
over here I'm good okay good okay okay
so it was definitely funny and it's
about energy I knew he wasn't taking no
[__] ah so you could yeah that is a big
thing reading people's energy and that
kind of stuff huh so sometimes you have
to bail out of them because you know I
built it out there he kind of like
because I didn't want him sitting think
like or catch on it was a prank and then
sometimes you tell me what's right and
make them even more matter so I never
tell nobody it's a prank because now
that you embarrass me on camera and you
record it now I'm pissed off so
sometimes you just have to walk away and
just let it be that and let them find
out you know what's funny what I think
about is when they go home and tell the
story and they don't know it's gonna be
viral it's like yeah some [__] punk
came up to me and I had to slap him and
he lied and then comes out on camera and
it'll be like bro this is the one [__]
happened this might be like damn hey I
had to get something he's like look
Belinda I gotta tell you we ain't going
that [__] Golden Corral anymore yeah
yeah yeah they up there they got a damn
uh Warden up their damn [__] dinner
Ward right and he's accusing people and
they're like brother slap the [__] out
of them we were like oh you did yeah I
can't go back it did the camera come out
and then he never slapped them that's
one thing I really be like damn when
people see this how do they feel and
she's just rubbing his arm baby you only
had two players baby right I know I
[__] know it right damn that's crazy
bro do um and it's interesting because I
don't think like as a white guy I
wouldn't be brave enough to go do that
[__] I think like to a black eye
wouldn't be brave enough to go do it and
it's really about
sometimes like it ain't even about the
colors about the energy right right
that's a good point this is the thing
like sometimes we can get so caught up
in the [__] cover of us but who
are they in the inside because at the
end of the day we still got souls and
then if I sweat and I was in your color
right now we swapped I would still be
mean your [__] color yeah so
sometimes this is like some people are
naturally [__] no matter if you
black Mexican white or whatever the [__]
you are yo so it's gonna be your soul so
the thing is it's kind of like we are in
the Shell so it's really like who you
are as a person that's what I said me I
love myself and I know at the end of the
day I'ma love what's around me so the
thing with me is like you're innocent
until proven guilty so I don't give a
[__] about color at the end of the day I
see you as a [__] person and
this is your image at the end of the day
who are you inside the image that's what
[__] matters gang bro I never really
I've never exactly heard it put to me
like uh heard it put like that that is
about the person's energy because
sometimes I will
when I'm talking about it about race and
stuff I sometimes fall into the Trap of
saying of kind of I don't know if it's
grouping people but you kind of
generalize you stereotype you stereotype
sometimes right but the truth is it
really is about somebody's energy some
people's energy you know just this ain't
the dude but then sometimes you could
get you're right because I could go and
get I might be able to find the perfect
black guy the perfect Mexican woman and
then the other black person would be
like if he did that to me I would have
right and then the same thing about a
white racist they say if he would have
tried me I would have yeah so you got
the would have right okay [__] big
deal I didn't do you right and there's a
reason I didn't do you because yeah I
know the energy and my energy
today it's not worth losing your life
doing a prank or at the day I try people
that's gonna go home I'm gonna cuss you
out I'm gonna go home to my family I'm
not trying to [__] with somebody that's
trying to lose it all over telling me I
got too many plates like no I don't even
want to [__] with you at this point bro
nobody should [__] with you you know so
this is like you don't want to [__] with
nobody that's right it's like going to
so how is it like going to a volcano
Volcan you when you know it's different
ones you know when one's about to erupt
I'm not about to go [__] yeah I'm not
going on that [__] yeah even animals at
the zoo I'm not walking up to a tiger
that's going crazy I go to the common
and just pray that I get the best
results yeah I go to that [__] on Xanax
yeah yeah that's a one I really feel
like that's why I push this a mindset
thing because it's really about your
mind and that's what people have to
start looking at that sometimes it's not
even about the [__] color because I
think they you got Nikes you got Reeboks
but guess what they still choose they do
different [__] by the end of the day
you're gonna wear them we are still
saying [__] people we just have a we
do have our different images and colors
but inside who the [__] are we right
yeah it's interesting because I get like
I think I know that right but it's hard
sometimes because nobody look at it like
that right I haven't I've never heard it
put like that so I've never really been
able to put it kind of into that sort of
context or words you know because um
yeah and that just it's just like some
people you kind of match up with some
people you don't you do it's best if you
try to run if you're trying to run a
prank or somebody or somebody right
um yeah that one the one you did because
some a lot of audience may know you a
lot of them may not right and that's
just the way that social media is right
um
the one you did with the baby powder
with that guy dog oh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was great yeah
let me tell you about this baby powder
though this one is the one that you
I'm looking a little tiny One
Clap clack
and then a lot of uh and what are you
doing so you go into Walmart yeah hold
on I don't know why hold on man this is
gonna be the greatest moment of my life
I gotta sit here with you honestly um
and uh and that's what I said I got
greats that I look up to this like uh
where I didn't know where I was going
into with that yeah no idea no I didn't
but I was just like I got to get them
with something because I had a Walmart
bed so I just wanted to get a good video
and shout out to Ed Bassmaster Ed Ed was
there no no that he does that he does
the the face so I look like these people
I look up to and then I just look and be
like how can I do it in my way so in
some [__] I create and some people I
recreate so I'm of a person that I'm not
afraid to say that I recreate something
I love it if it's funny I'll go do it
yeah yeah but it's just doing it right
that's the thing some people do [__] and
it's like bro you're not even doing it
do it better to me at least if you're
gonna do it right I'm saying yeah like
that's just what it is so there's some
people I study they pranks him like I
love this this is what I like and then I
go out and be like okay let me do it
into my way wow that's what it's about
yeah everything is [__] everybody got
on Yeezys but they're not wearing it how
you wearing it yeah can't say take them
[__] off because I'm wearing them you
know what I'm saying right yeah I think
I do so
um
so do you feel like yeah do you feel
like a comedian do you feel like a
prankster uh I'm sitting here with funny
marker I didn't even introduce you and I
feel bad and uh where are you where are
you from where did you start out at so
I'm from Kansas City Missouri oh wow now
I have been over there they used to have
Albertson I was at Barbara's barbecue
yeah they got games and then they got
Stacks uh Jack Stacks house uh so yeah
so I came from Kansas City Missouri and
it's it's really like a a small it's a
small state yeah so then I moved to
Atlanta so the thing is when I moved to
Atlanta I left with
you know what's crazy you know how my
[__] started it was a random guy he DM
me he was like you got a manager this
was Thanksgiving like 2000
2019 he DME and you've been praying
about it or anything I mean I wanted to
move from Kansas City I was trying to
move to St Louis I didn't give a [__] I
just wanted to get oh you go anywhere
you got a manager and I'm like no he's
like uh bro Rihanna just followed you
and I'm like where this is what I'm like
what and he was this is I'm like damn I
get hyped he's like bro you need to
manager he's like come come out to
Atlanta I didn't know this this guy from
McKenna Bank yeah so I'm like [__] it
I'm going like I didn't have nothing to
lose at this point I believed in myself
I went out to Atlanta met him stayed in
his damn room didn't know this so I can
start damn yeah so I was there with him
he was talking about manage me and stuff
shout out to him and it's just kind of
like from there it was like risk-taking
can help you or hurt you you know what
I'm saying because I could have gotten
that but I got so much good energy in
myself I feel like I believe in like
good energy whatever you manifest you're
gonna go towards that and you're gonna
get bad [__] too I got bad [__] in that
experience but I still was able overall
I did what I want to do in the outcome I
made it good but it was some bad [__]
but life is like a web you know in high
school they have the big web and it goes
out like
and it's just you're gonna get some good
[__] you're gonna get some bad [__] but
you just gotta keep pulling [__] from
that main web which is you you got to
keep drawing [__] out
what kind of bad [__] did you come
across damn uh not knowing the game not
knowing business working no isn't that
hard yeah like I'm like how the [__] can
I make money I remember the first the
first money I made on Instagram was ten
thousand dollars for a post and guess
what the [__] it was no uh my [__]
god guess what item you think it was I
had to let me think
it was something like what the [__] am I
gonna do with this it was a girl Idol
oh like a vibrator
sexual
um
a gun
uh now like a recipe book
what was it
oh I know what it was ancestry.com
it was a waist trainer
so I'm like I'm not I'm like what the
[__] I'm not about to and then at this
point about where it is like people are
gonna start you know and I'm like what
the I mean then he already took the ten
thousand dollars he says trainer to lose
weight weight training for women oh so
just crank them up if they're trying to
get rid of a baby too you'll see
somebody put that yeah but he said
whatever the [__] it is make it funny
you got ten thousand dollars waiting for
you get it done I'm sending it over to
you while you're transfer so I'm sitting
there like what the [__] I'm I'm
irritated because he already took the
money and that's a lot of money if I'm
not making nothing and oh yeah and that
was a lot of money and I'm like the
thing is I was caring about people
business I'm like how can I make her
happy I wasn't thinking about that I'm
like I want her to be happy here y'all
know what to do no it was a random my
manager took a deal from somebody oh
okay the person yeah it was a random
person that's to say he's like I want to
give him I want him I'm thinking you out
there [__] listening to Umbrella
thinking how can I make this [__]
he just this is when I got to Atlanta
this was like a bad situation for me but
I thought it was good okay I was like
freaked out so you got the trainer it
shows up in the mail yeah I get it I go
to Walmart this is kind of the time uh
I'm at Walmart too I got booked for
Walmart for the essence uh Festival that
they got in Louisiana yeah then I'm down
there I got this [__] waist trainer
I'm like what the [__] I'm not putting
it on what the [__] can I do with a
waist trainer the whole time I'm
thinking and then I'm like [__] so then
I go to a random customer and I'm like
I'm like do y'all got any more of these
uh I forgot waitress I don't work here
so I'm like okay and then the kicks in
I'm like you sure go back there and give
me another one he's like I don't work
here I'm like bro I'm like I just saw
you he's like I don't [__] work here
and I'm like got it I said so now I
could go with the customers ask them
about the waist training say the name of
it and I'm showing it get them pissed
off boys trying to promote it bam got it
so then I do I do that I get this old
lady bro you got to see this clip y'all
got to pull it up I get this
old lady
she's like
she's like a Christian I don't know and
I'm like do you got this waist trainer
she's like oh I don't work your baby and
I'm like you don't work here so my
brother's sitting there is like I don't
work here and then she's like I don't
work here God damn it what the [__] and
she goes
and she said y'all recording me and then
I look at him in my head I'm like [__]
we got a viral moment I'm like I can't
[__] this up I don't want her to delete
this I'm like we're not recording you
she said because I'm a member of a
church you can't get this you cannot put
that out so long story short I'm like no
we're not record you in my head I'm
happy as hell because now I have that
moment that waist trainer this is about
to set this [__] off yeah I get the [__]
send it to the lady she's like I don't
like it
I'm like what the [__] this is it like
this she's like I don't you should have
this why don't you say this promote show
me more say the name and and this at
this moment I was getting so many people
and I do it to one video 59 seconds I'm
getting I'm like bro it's their clear as
day we got good moments she's like being
a [__] she's like she doesn't know that
yeah like I'm like this is this is the
plan is the moment let me do this like
yeah she like no I don't want and then
I'm like [__] so then
I'll go back and forth in my man he's
like make it funny so then she's like
I'm like [__] this is the moment I want
to release it at this point like [__]
the 10 I want people because at this
time I wanna I I'm content I'm like put
it out content this is gonna go viral so
then she ends up uh
she end up like not like I don't approve
it I put it out anyway I still wouldn't
go get the money it goes viral goes on
TV it goes on uh it was a show I forgot
what that show was called it goes on TV
everywhere and it's just blowing up
she's like oh my God I didn't and I
still tagged her and everything she's
like I got over 10 000 followers it went
crazy it's on there like people are
hitting me up now other influencers are
writing me saying cannot can I work for
me people I used to DM they never said
nothing to me so I'm so appreciated I
want to see you another ten thousand
dollars take that one I'm ready for the
next video so there it was just kind of
money funny how like you can have lumps
in life but just understand don't get
blocked by them like sometimes people
run into the big round don't know what's
behind it sometimes you gotta probably
curve it or you're gonna have to knock
that [__] down and just know so you're
in your example there is that you put up
you said this is it I know this is yeah
this is a ride I'm just about to show
yeah I'm just about to show her even if
I got to do a new one cool but she about
to see it so I still tagged the company
at the end of the day it's still free
video about the same time it was still
promotion for me because it went big it
hit a million views and it was reposted
on there so I still benefited from it
and then she ended up seeing my vision
then I started at a trend after I went
up I started doing other items like that
right so not only that Viral moment I
came up with I'm like now I have a
series where I can do other people
product with this and this prank and I
can use this cup or the item or backwood
or anything so then I'm going in Walmart
asking people do you work here this I
had this item and you know what I'm
saying it's so funny because it's like
pissing them off and it's just like yeah
so and then that's when it came into
like a tragic like you know what I'm
saying like so they but yet you didn't
get paid for that first video I did she
liked it she did after she realized it
yeah you ran the risk and not getting
paid yeah I see what you're saying yeah
yeah you have to it's interesting to
rely on your own instincts and vision
man like in Hollywood I got caught for a
while I I felt like I was trying to fit
into Hollywood you know trying to get on
television show or do this or that and
then finally I said you know a lot of
these places that wouldn't give me any
opportunity they don't put up a lot of
kind of guys I'm not even really a
southern guy but I'm from the south you
know they don't put a lot of that on
television you know
um and everybody would just kind of
pigeonhole like that and this and so
finally I just said I'm gonna start just
kind of doing my own stuff and we
started just podcasting and putting out
clips that we thought were good and that
kind of evolved in at least having our
own Universe you know but it's it's hard
sometimes to believe that oh this is
hard it was hard uh I'm not hard
no no no no I mean I'm not hard I mean I
uh
I take those pills a lot you ever take
them is it horny in here
I don't think it's uh is it horny in
here no I'll be using it on some of my
girls sometimes it's always morning in
here yeah just say that next time you're
with a girl just like is it horny in
here yeah yeah it worked dude I flirted
with a girl last night actually where
what's her name
um she was kind of this she's a she was
kind of like a mixed girl I think and
she was a little bit so what's your
definition of flirting though
being close to somebody and talking to
them not be like being brave enough to
look right at him while you're talking
right we're not close are we no we're
not we know this is we're safe enough we
should okay this is a straight distance
this is a straight male distance okay
um
you know I was in a car accident
probably about four years ago
some lady did a u-turn and she didn't
know how to do it and she just
she you turned right into me it was more
of a j and I was at the end of the J
and I got just jacked up that's what
happened
if you're ever injured
in a car accident or injured at all and
in some type of accident you can check
out Morgan and Morgan
Morgan and Morgan is America's largest
injury Law Firm they have over 100
offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars were
covered for clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting
till you get your full and fair
compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
Morgan is so easy it's more like using
an app than hiring a lawyer
with Morgan and Morgan you can submit a
claim without ever having to leave the
couch and you might not be able to heck
if you're hurt if you're ever injured
you can check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com
this past weekend
or dial pound law that's pound 529 from
your cell phone that's f o r the
people.com
this past weekend or pound 529 from your
cell phone this is a paid advertisement
you know I'm a big fan of Raising Canes
you know it I mean well you got to know
it I just love them those chicken
fingers my goodness
they just do it for me
I like that Caniac combo
and the sauce man that that cane sauce
it just takes everything to another
level that is a just a dang beautiful
dip God
they got the crinkle cut fries they got
that buttery Texas toast
and the secret over there is they make
it when you order it
those fingers aren't just Milling around
baby they go right into boot camp when
you order and they come out ready to
salute your taste buds
now that your mouth is watering I gotta
let you know that it's so easy to order
on the mobile app that's right Keynes
has their own mobile app or you can go
online at raising canes.com that's
r-a-i-s-i-n-g
c-a-n-e-s.com you gotta check them out
it's amazing satisfy your Cane's fix
fast by ordering through their app
online at raising canes.com or stop by
your local restaurant
or to be honest if you just need a
little whiff you could probably smell my
breath half of the week because I'm
caned up baby gang
but I don't know if she liked me or not
I started talking to another guy after
me huh
the chick man the same girl no you said
you started talking to who this girl I
don't remember her name yeah and then
you start talking to who after her oh I
didn't oh I tried to talk to some other
girl but she kept looking at some she
was like looking away every time I was
like she was like and then she kept
dancing did she know who you was though
do you look look let me first question
uh how can I say this because I'm not a
racist how can I say because I don't
want to say it's all right if you're a
little racist hmm I mean if you are like
you know I say I'll be racist towards
certain [__] like when somebody say I
don't eat like the edge of the Pop-Tarts
I feel like you're racist toward
Pop-Tarts I look at racist [__] like
that not color how do girls say like she
said she don't eat off uh paper plates I
feel like she racist toilet paper plates
oh yeah what the [__] did they do to you
yeah that's crazy so like I said racist
ain't even all about color sometimes
like you're racist towards something
right oh you could be racist towards
anything right like owls yeah my buddy
hates owls I'm like damn yeah right
yeah but look okay so all right so how
how can I say this if I was not to say
YP what's the Caucasians you can say uh
Caucasians I think are drug or that's
drugs but I think you could say
Caucasians you could say call you could
say honkies if you want I don't know
that sounds terrible that's too much
yeah yeah you're trying to get me
canceled yeah that's true yeah you could
say yeah yeah that was a good one yeah
yeah that was a good one you could do uh
oh it's like a good white person that is
just like a general white person a group
of them yeah yeah like uh because we
African-Americans right so I would say
um
uh
kind of like
I don't know if you just want to say
white Americans white Americans that
just sound too like they're trying to be
you're trying to troll us yeah yeah I
agree so I would say just uh and then
what if you say people like you that's
kind of going too far well people like
you people get offended at that yeah
yeah yeah you know you can't say these
people people like you gay so whatever
yeah what is the right term to say what
do you have Zach do you have anything
for whites
a group of whites
um I think usually just people calling
them those whites over there so that's
crazy
I don't know yeah so I'm saying what is
it so uh so some people
people people you might know so people
of your kind okay that sounds a little
bit people of your kind people of your
kind that sounds good that sounds kind
of cleaned up like okay so people of
your kind how do y'all flicks like you
do you realize like sometimes you like
you like her like you know the [__] I am
how do you Flex on somebody when they
turn you down
do y'all Flex let me think I think some
guys do if they're Brave guys right what
about you like how you ever Flex on girl
like you know what the [__] I am like in
your head we're not actually saying that
no one time I got out of an elevator and
this guy had gotten in he was listening
to my podcast when he got in and I've
been flirting with the girl in the
elevator right and so this kid and she
was not giving me the time what was this
[__] elevator right this was seven
seven stories okay so it all happened
pretty quick I got in she got in we're
both in there and I'd seen her before
dude and she was there I think with her
mom or something and they had a dog she
kept walking this dog outside of the
elevator and or outside of the hotel so
I'm like oh man I've been praying about
this and I saw her in the elevator and
then this kid gets in he's like no way
I'm listening to your podcast right now
and I and I had just said hey if you
want to come to a comedy show tonight
and she goes oh I think we're busy
tonight right she kind of brushed me off
and then this kid gets in and he's like
no way and so then I felt our energy
change a little bit and as I'm getting
out he goes you know that guy is and I
look back and uh and I could see
something in her
was like a little bit different but it
didn't matter that was it the doors
closed
but I did let it happen I look back and
said I'd let her know I know what's
going on so hey like I just asked me
questions that I want to know are you
welcome to ask me questions but like how
do you approach girls in public because
I never seen like you know I got like
white friends I got all type but I never
seen a world like I think she's cute I'm
gonna talk to her like I never why you
guys aren't as Brave yeah that's what I
just I'm like how the hell do y'all get
dates
oh [__] I don't know mostly DMs I think
parents set you up see there it is
Stephanie yeah like I want you to talk
to Stephanie she's my best friend dirty
like [__] it yeah we gotta do it yeah
yeah but that's better too because it's
Word of Mouth versus just meeting a
stranger because then if [__] comes back
home or if she ever steal from you your
[__] daughter stole my twenty dollars
right that's true I think there's danger
well a lot of [__] steal yeah a lot
of [__] steal oh you check your
pockets yeah
I don't know it was fun I've never done
that either bro I ain't stole nothing
yet I used to steal did you really yeah
dude um is that like a is that a part of
sometimes people do it because they want
to try it and some people do it because
they can't like can't afford it right so
it's just it's like where the hell you
at with it so like doing it just because
other people doing it is totally
unacceptable if you can't like you know
one time like I stole a steak from
Walmart it was crazy so I slid it down
my pants so I put the steak down like I
was in the whole time I'm like I'm like
where the [__] I'm gonna put this steak
at so I'm like [__] because you know it
comes like in a plastic thing yeah steak
so they're nice huh yeah yeah so I said
[__] it took it out the thing okay I had
the steak in my hand yeah slid it right
in here I'm like who the [__] gonna
check
[Music]
the steak is out of here
like if you search yeah yeah like what
did he say oh you stole the state but he
just keep rubbing on your dick bro like
that sexual assault like you can't do
that that's true that's sexual assault
it's not part like man a lot of things
get bait and switched like that now
people will set up something and then
they'll end up getting a lawsuit too
yeah yeah so uh long story short uh yeah
I went to jail the state got took it
nobody ate the state they probably put
it back on the market so probably
something that's a big steak out there
yeah so if you're watching this just
watch out
I would have uh I wonder what I would
eat man say a white person dies right
say you guys are at a uh I never been I
want to go to a white funeral I want to
see how this dude there's a lot of
crying
oh uh it's a lot of people playing like
um Jesse McCartney listening to Jesse
McCartney uh I'll check it out I want
you and your beautiful soul you're the
one I wanna take
you're the one I Wanna Hold You Don't
Jesse McCartney do you know uh all y'all
ladies pop y'all [__] like this
yeah yeah that's black funeral yeah
Jesus they played it for the strippers
God where oh [__] a lot of funerals like
that's what happened because that's the
theme song so they go out to that and a
lot of strippers they had a stripper
pole it was one girl her name was
Dominique and she like had a crazy
stripper like party like it was like a
strip hole at the thing and it was a
celebration yeah because that's what she
she like that was what she stood up for
so they was playing that and like [__]
everywhere and [__] like oh my God what
it makes me nervous hearing about all of
that I don't like hearing about
a lot of us call it Cooter or whatever
growing up but are you scared of Cooter
I'm not scared of it there's not too
much of it it just makes something about
it man when people start talking about
it or
especially I think during the daytime
but after five six p.m I'll hear about
it
um you know what was uh
why tell me about this thing can I ask
you questions about being black yeah
okay thank you
um only two okay all right cool cool
what uh
what does it feel like does it feel
different
like does it feel like when you I mean
I've never been another color so I don't
know what it's like feeling different
but does it like what does it feel like
uh I feel like being black be in this
color
does it feel like anything or does it I
feel like you know what everybody got
their super powers so we got some more
advantages y'all got some of y'alls yeah
like you know I just want to know
sometimes what it's like to cuss the
police out like what the [__] did you
put me over for back the [__] up but you
know we can't do that so it's like gifts
encouragement so many times y'all can't
go out in the hood and fight y'all can't
fight but we can right so we gotta pick
our battles you know yeah at the end of
the day it's like we can survive in the
trenches you know what the trenches are
yeah I know what that I mean I haven't
been in all of them but I've seen
something but what's your ideas of the
detention The Trenches I think it's
people are eating hot dogs people are
you know there's people fighting
probably uh somebody has a gun little
booty has a gun or something
uh people
selling um
Stacks or whatever people not stat you
know what I'm saying people talking
about uh
let me get that
you know and they got a secret gay dude
in there too let me get that booty I see
let me get that booty I see you know
what I'm talking about or like uh oh
people I know what let me tell you uh uh
people listening to [__] Boosie you
know you know you know any of his lyrics
yeah dude
um yeah I do we got some of his lyrics
written down at home but like being that
I just feel like we uh we just got our
advantages you know and I just feel like
it comes back to be comfortable because
God made us who we are for a [__]
reason and I believe in reincarnation
like eventually I might be white or I
might be a turtle when I thought I die
you know like I might not ever been like
you might get through like like them and
you would probably get to be like damn I
remember like you won't remember it all
but you're like yeah I used to be right
now I'm like so that's why sometimes
some people say oh you act black or you
act white because they've been white
before and now they're in the black body
oh yeah so and then some people like
might be a snapping turtle I definitely
know when I die I'm gonna be a seahorse
I could see you out there yeah I'm just
like over it you know I could see you
out there yeah I'm not being like I
because I've been here before I just I
just I'll be remembering bike flashes
like black people seem like they've been
here before yeah no I mean this I say
Souls I'm not gonna say black people so
well okay I would say this a lot of
black children that I see even six month
old nine I like my short like the dude I
want to kill my mom yeah they act like
they have very much so that's what I'm
saying sometimes I see black children
that seem like they've been here I get
it yeah very Advanced they're like over
[__] and they're [__] 11 months
events in this [__] yeah he
already like trying to go to the senior
care center it comes from like or like
Mama's like because black women got good
coochie oh damn really yeah
all right
okay that's one question so what was the
answer to it uh being able to accept our
advantages so being black yeah yeah but
y'all got some too but right everybody
has different advantages yeah yeah right
right yeah that's what I think is kind
of okay sometimes it's okay to joke
about certain things about people that
are kind of like just normal things that
everybody can kind of recognize like I
don't count that kind of stuff as racism
to me you know like if somebody's mean
or really ill will then that's different
you know
um but I noticed that uh all right
what's the theory with I I uh black
people eat more watermelon and white I
think white people eat watermelon more
than black people
oh I would think probably so especially
now because once black people heard that
[__] I think they don't even [__] with
it anymore because that seemed like uh
black people always seem like they want
to be unique they want to do their own
[__] that's what it seems like to me
yeah it's definitely Saucy like we
definitely create a lot of [__] right
and also I think you know America was
kind of I don't know if it was like
I don't know if it was like a white
culture when black people first got here
so it would make sense that black people
would not want to do they would want to
only do [__] that seems new and we just
like we want to start a lot of [__] and
we come from like you know being a [__]
and just kind of like just you know what
I'm saying I just feel like it's really
in our like just trying new [__] from
the way we dress the way we do music so
very talented you know and everybody
talented but we learn how to do [__] and
turn it into like our way like and just
keep in mind Mexicans do the same [__]
they find ways and you know what I'm
saying y'all do the same [__] but you
will never know until like you be around
and see it you know because I got I got
I grew up around my uncle had a white
girlfriend so we met the the you know
what was her name do you remember
Jennifer oh damn
so he got to me and that's what I said I
can relate to the whitest name in too
yeah he did yeah he brought Jennifer
around and then I could tell was funny
because she was so comfortable with us
boom she brought us around the family it
was like she broke the [__] cold like
but and then sometimes it'd be like that
for like you know babe like don't bring
that white [__] to my house so it'd be
so some families like you broke the code
right so and that's what I said where it
leads in with certain people and some
people accept it like oh like you know
so it's it's just getting where you
feeling if you're uncomfortable with it
don't be around but she definitely broke
the code bringing us over to
Thanksgiving especially in in the food
wasn't I didn't like the food so not
only that like the food was not right
yeah it was different yeah but I really
feel like if you do do that get let the
family know talk to him don't make it
awkward you know what I'm saying like
yeah that's a good point it's better to
say hey I'm bringing over an Indian or a
Native American I'm bringing over a
Swedish guy or a woman or a black guy or
a Japanese woman and see how everybody
feels yeah yeah overall when they lead
into it all the stuff we talk about it's
just crazy because we still are soul and
just talking about colors it's just a
subject to talk about because there's
nobody talking about that's a what a
Roku TV nobody arguing about Samsung
versus Roku it's just a [__] TV but
it just they made it a big thing with
colors at the end of the day nobody's
arguing about Jordan and Nike is his
[__] shoes but so when it comes into
Color Race I feel like when we all come
mature and we just let it be you [__]
human I'm [__] human you shouldn't
piss our sleep I Gotta Eat You Gotta Eat
and leave it at that it'll be cool yeah
once everybody come to do it it's gonna
probably take 20 years a generation like
we all won that's all that [__]
matters yeah we talk about down here a
lot about beige power like eventually
everybody's going to be beige
everybody's going to be like Ben Simmons
yeah everybody's gonna be six eleven
how'd you feel if you woke up like would
you be like wow
oh I would be excited I think I'd be
excited oh yeah dude every every white
person's dream I think is to wake up
black low-key for sure because I got to
get up and be [__] black dog remember
uh Chris Brown when they and they did
that body thing for the video oh yeah
yeah I do remember that
yeah dude I would love it dude I would
first of all I would sneak up on people
that didn't know I was gonna be black
bro [__] surprise them white people
because they'd be like oh [__] I'm
scared and I'd be like it's me
[__] yeah I was surprising bro
yeah and then what would I do
I think I would just like
see what it feels like to just
say [__] no I wouldn't say it
I might write it down I would write it
down text it
yeah
guess who's here and then they say who
this ah yeah
BBWs
oh yeah you [__] with them I would then
oh I'd hook up with every thick white
girl that drives a Honda Civic dawg
because that's all I remember when I was
growing up all the black dudes had the
white girl with the Honda Civic yeah now
you yeah you know something they had
they had that bro they had a
like I'm gonna tell you kind of like the
three things that you need to to Bob in
the hood you got to surround around the
right people
not like you know what I'm saying not
the overly people that's dangerous and
not the only you got to get with the
ones that's kind of like civilized they
know not to [__] with us that's one
thing so you got to know who to click
with you'll never know okay that's one
thing and another thing you need a
[__] Shank
so this shank is just kind of like this
back up off of me Google it shank
s-h-a-n-k yeah Shank
so a shank is just to kind of like to
protect yourself to be like back up
this is kind of like I don't want I'm
not that type of person but if you got
this close to me to me to use it yeah
you deserve it oh damn so it's a
closeness issue just pull up a shank
Zach yeah you need one of them oh damn
bro yeah you need one [__] coming all
sizes same boy and that thing like if
you get close to me uh by the way you
look like Tom Brady a little bit uh
thanks man uh but if you get that close
to me then that means like you you
deserve this because you was in my space
like you can't just do that this is kind
of like a oh I see it's a close yeah
there's you out of the way of the shank
you're good you got my way damn uh
that's one thing and then uh you know
what A Link Card is a Link Card uh-uh oh
like a DBT EBT yeah EBT yeah and I ain't
gonna lie they say is that's true they
say more white people get food stamps
than black people we had food stamps
growing up I remember no but they said
the coach I wonder if we did like I know
you can look it up yeah they said more
there's a lot of wealthy black people
now bro yeah than there used to be when
I was like it was but it was never on
The Radars because it was like top like
drug dealers we couldn't talk about it
but now you the internet shows it more
legitimate but back then it's always
been a lot of good black people but we
couldn't talk about it because we did
like we did it how we had to do it right
yeah it was more criminal yeah we
couldn't like [__] on the five right
and I feel like sometimes nine of fives
need to be better with that [__] let's
talk about that nah
because it's [__] up it's a scam
because ain't no way I'm working for
Walmart y'all making a million dollars a
day and y'all only giving me nine
dollars an hour this [__] sucks I can
wake up somebody I can rank up
20 people and they spending over 300 and
I only get nine dollars proud of this
raise that [__] up yeah thirty dollars
an hour is not bad Walmart and that's
how you stop the revolving door that's
why so many [__] people in Walmart
but it means you ran a franchise [__] it
let's pay our customers 100 an hour it's
gonna stop the revolving door it's gonna
stop the hiring progress and we don't
have to [__] worry about like you
know what I'm saying because you spend
so much money people quitting coming in
and coming out drug screening you spend
them a lot of [__] so if you give a home
imagine if you get 100 an hour you
Walmart you would be it will be a team
you'll know
Stacy Kim Lisha Brenda Keisha all them
they will all be these same people all
we get a hundred dollars but they treat
them like [__] same [__] with McDonald's
yeah come the [__] on you can't give us
40 an hour I'm here busting my ass
serving Big Macs in and out and getting
cussed out getting traded like [__] and
they got pedophiles in there it's hard
as hell to serve something you know they
got a man out there trying to touch
you know in a little uh
in the play area yeah them [__] was
always out there in ours you'd go out
there dog you you playing I don't know
what what McDonald's you went to but we
you know Covington Louisiana bro we
being that [__] they had a dude always
out there
did he have like let's talk about this I
have a thing so this is something that I
think about sometimes sometimes I always
felt like a lot of black people thought
like oh white people have it so good
about work and stuff but then
the whole time I was [__] working for
somebody for sh you know it was like
sometimes it was felt like there was a
perception that it was better
and and I know probably black people
couldn't get hired for stuff but then
there was this perception that it was
[__] great but then now you realize I
think now there's more some more
equality because you see like a black
dude's just like oh this [__] sucks
this is what I've been waiting to get to
and this is [__] [__]
and it shows where they kind of like
some jobs don't hire people because of
that and different franchises and that's
what they you I'm saying I get that
because it has happened where some
people want to go work for Delta but
they only hired a certain color that's
like what the coaches in the NFL where
they're saying they're getting more like
coaches in the NFL because they never
have so and then they get it they might
like it so that's what you're going with
like how they probably want something
and they get it's like damn this is not
what the [__] I wanted it's not what
it's saying well just that it didn't
like I think sometimes it felt like
there was this perception that it was so
great for like some white folks some
jobs but then you you get the job if
you're not white and you realize oh this
[__] wasn't even that great I thought it
was great for them but they're just up
here getting yeah I want better than
this [__] right yeah like it's like
sometimes if it's I would feel like
oh like some people thought like it was
magical being white but it wasn't it
just but I say but now it's just the now
you see everybody's on damn depression
it's just the same [__] I'm crying in my
car outside of a damn Jimmy John like
this is just it's nothing it's not
really that amazing for most people most
people are still working for even some
bigger fancier everything is right right
so that comes with people learning
theyself and that's when you're happy
with yourself you're not worried about
what the next [__] doing so
white black mace can once you worry
about you and you were about to [__]
your goal is you you won't you know what
I'm saying you don't have to deal with
that so it's a such thing that uh my
dead Grandpa that's still alive told me
he was just like basically when you're
driving your car you always got to look
forward but when you look back to look
at them little [__] it's a
chance to wreck are you gonna swerve so
at the end of they stay in your [__]
lane and mind your [__] business and
God gonna give you wherever you need to
go if you believe in God sorry some
people don't but that's just what I
gotta say but if you God gonna take you
wherever you gotta go and if you believe
in yourself you're gonna take you where
you need to go and that's it but you
cannot drive a car and feel like you're
gonna get where you need to go looking
back yeah and that's what you say where
people like them what they doing over
there I want to go over there and then
you [__] up and crash so it's been
really true to yourself and manifesting
so [__] all the race [__] wouldn't come
to that if you want that you can get it
you might get it somewhere else and you
can't get a job and and I'll get it I'm
from Kansas City Missouri They Don't
Really hire a lot of blacks on certain
jobs but I can't I come to Atlanta and I
see them it's a world they can do it
sometimes you can just remove out of
that place go to a new [__] State
yeah you know what I'm saying oh yeah
Atlanta it's [__] like February
started a city in that [__] and
it gives you a lot of opportunities so
wow when you see what happens to a
culture when they have a lot of money
it's pretty crazy right
because you didn't really they didn't
have it Atlanta wasn't like that like 30
years ago oh damn I I wouldn't know yeah
I was broke so I just know what I'm like
when I got money right but it's crazy
Atlanta's like it's a I mean in Atlanta
to see like a lot of black wealth it's
like the first city in America that you
really see like really really see it
yeah it's crazy bro yeah people riding
oh one of my boys uh uh baby daddy
sister cousin-in-law bought a [__]
Pony oh damn and you would never see a
black person with a pony bro yeah he
bought it for his daughter unreal yeah
that's [__] when you got power I
didn't know that was for real the ponies
are real oh I remember the first time I
saw a golden retriever bro an inside dog
at somebody's house I went somebody's
house and this dog came around the
corner and it was a golden retriever
bruh that's crazy I'd never seen a dog
inside
and that [__] blew my [__] mind I'd
never seen a dog that looked like it had
gotten some sleep
um and that [__] came around and had a
nice hair looked like Suzanne Summers
you know who that is
um no pull her up Susan Summer she
sounds familiar oh she was beautiful
what are some things that you like to do
let me think I like to podcasts I like
to do stand up do you do stand up that's
her right yeah oh yeah I've seen her
before
she sells a lot of uh pills and uh
Fitness porn star no she just looks like
that she sells a lot of pills and
fitness equipment oh
um what are some stuff I like to do I
like to uh watch college basketball and
I like to uh I've been looking for a
wife so I'm thinking about that what do
you look for right I don't know I want
somebody that's going to be a good
mother and I want somebody that has like
a nice look in their eyes like when I
look in their eyes they seem
genuine you know they just have honest
eyes you know so do you what do you feel
like you bring to a woman that changed
what do a woman get for [__] with you
what do you bring to the table
[Music]
besides money
no I mean I don't not I mean I bring
some different uh
massage dick
yeah and I don't even bring the great I
mean I bring
entry-level dick
what's that
it's like
the dick that would work in the mail
room I'm not a big I'm not the best you
know you don't have big dick energy I
got a decent my wiener is decent but I
don't have yeah I don't have I'm not
like uh I'm not [__] someone all
night like some psychopath or whatever
that's insane to me yeah you know if I
if somebody so what do you call somebody
that's just [__] like from like ten
to three
saying that's not like a damn uh
a migrant work or something that's not
like somebody that's got a million
dollars you couldn't do that
[__] from ten to three yeah not a chance
for one million yeah
not a chance if stop
five minute break get back to it stop
no you think you'll die
I don't think I'll die I think I would
give up I would realize that I don't
have it in me I think I would
I don't know I would coach the person
though that's what I would do I would be
a better Coach I would be a better
Corner guy for the dude during the five
minutes get over there you know put the
ice on his back you're doing good Ronnie
or whatever coach him up that's what I
would be um so you'll be like a
cameraman
no I'm being a cameraman I ain't
watching that [__] that's but you got it
for you to tell them what to do better
you gotta watch
yeah maybe I do have to yeah I would
probably have like a monitor I don't
want to hold the camera but I would
watch the Monitor and Coach him
yeah give him that water bottle like
that durable what's wrong with the what
the camera man
how do you feel about like pouring
cameramans like what do you think they
do can you imagine them like what do you
if he was the paint a picture of a porno
star camera God what do you just see him
as
I see him as a dude probably long
mustache probably a little bit of skeet
hanging off of that [__] they got he
got caught in a
Cross skeeting or whatever in a gang
bang and that's and he's that thing just
hanging off just like icicles you know
um
I see him probably dead like either
death's desperate for sex really if you
that close you gotta watch sex with a
little machine or something you got to
be that and use seven inches from some
[__] or something
I don't think you're doing real good you
think that it's just kind of like he's
being horny the whole time oh I think
he's grossly horny I think he how much
do you think they make
hey they don't like can you look that up
yeah how much does it make porn camera
person well I can tell you I know other
freelance camera guys who do that and
it's usually an hourly rate you know
um I bet probably at least a thousand to
two thousand a day no way for sure the
actresses are only getting 600.
I I'll look it up but I'm I would but
that I mean if he if he recording it he
got it would I be a cameraman yeah yeah
I actually I probably could see myself
doing that actually doing it and just
kind of like I wear overalls with
glasses I have a toothpick in my mouth
yeah and I I'll be so dope I'm like you
[__] that [__] up so I'll be like
they know it's me and then I'll Stand
Out to have my own camera production but
I have my whole goal is to stand out and
then I end up getting away from porn and
shooting movies and then oh you [__]
that [__] up and I had that saying when
people see me like oh that's the [__]
[__] up dude so then I have my own fan
base and I get booked for clubs and I
become [__] famous yeah so sometimes
you could take the worst job and just
make the best out of it because like I
told you I used to work at McDonald's
you won't believe it yeah I didn't know
that you worked out yeah I was the dude
like when people get double patties I
just slid one out and just give them
like you know one single and they're
like single Patty man
because I don't think you need all that
meat that's crazy I well I uh I think it
depends I mean people you know I'm not
judging or anything but I think people
want they meet you know if you if you
drive around the building like how much
meat do you be taking
I mean I'll be honest with you I had
McDonald's last night I had three
patties that's crazy
I have one quarter pounder and two
cheeseburger patties you know what's the
most meat you could take you think I'm
gonna take meat you stole that steak
yeah I tried
I couldn't get it yeah went to jail and
ever since then I changed my life damn
bro welcome back yeah do you uh do you
[__] with mystical or anything like that
do you listen anything let's go danger
yeah get on the floor he was unique man
right here he's singing he yelled all
the [__] time he did he was angry
about something uh how do you feel about
post Malone uh it was a thing another
one get your side where they feel like
uh this is from Charlemagne to God he
said he feel like he came over and
stole like the Black Culture with the
right Iverson then he went over and just
changed and never made nothing for that
how do you feel about that like do you
agree with him or disagree I think that
that's silly for Charlemagne to say I
think at this point
at some point we got to realize that
there's oh I think there's been a lot of
culture vultures over the years
especially early on when
when black people didn't have a lot of
rights to their music when they they
didn't even know about business like
even growing up poor and white like I've
had to learn I've made a lot of Port
like business choice because I don't
have anybody in my family doing anything
in my business because it was poor so
you made poor decisions that makes sense
yeah nobody was doing any business
nobody at Rich you started making Rich
decisions yeah and then you start to
know other rich people they tell you
[__] you know Charlemagne I think kind
of have a
he seemed like oh
a little bit he seemed like a he have a
kind of a womanly look he's beautiful
yeah
you think that
who Charlemagne it's beautiful you think
he's beautiful I mean I [__] with Megan
and style you're so cute
yeah what if it was me and Charlemagne
in a room dude you tell me Charlemagne
ain't fine bro come on though you think
that's a sex symbol
I think if you put a if he was in Japan
or uh a week
if he was a uh yeah oh you put him in a
wig dog some basketball players gonna
[__] him
thank you
what about a podcaster like what a hat
on
I don't know right yeah yeah I'm not
just speaking I'm just saying not you
why not we're not talking about no no
okay okay yeah I wouldn't do it no no I
wouldn't tell my job I'm just saying
somebody that do podcasters and wear
hats and like that speak their [__]
mind and they like green sweaters and
[__]
yeah I don't know if they would do that
too yeah
uh but yeah I don't I think for like a
sexy uh when they come to women like
your women Crush oh my women cry how do
you feel about Britney Spears I used to
love her man because she was from
Louisiana that's where I'm from so I
loved her man what you all loved her but
it was all she was 16 now
she's gone off man I think somebody did
something bad to her I think they were
pilling her up is she still Rich yeah
she's still rich but I think they were
putting pills in her and doing stuff
like that you know that's what I think
um what do what do you think about her
uh I feel like she just sometimes I just
feel like people do what they want to do
and I feel like she from what we I heard
the documentary she got held back from
like living her life so now this is her
time to do it so sometimes people can
miss out on the opportunity because
people like them this is what I want to
do I feel like now she's getting to live
our life that's my opinion oh like now
she's free yeah oh it's like damn she
didn't get to learn like you know or it
might be I got I'm living on a such
thing as it's not no bad because if you
do it you're just gonna live in your
results so no matter what you do just
know it's not a bad thing just know
you're gonna live what comes with it and
if you don't want to live with it just
don't do it that's what said I'm not a
racist I'm not a like [__] I just
live in good spirit you know because
I don't want to do nothing I don't
regret like you know one time I got
slapped and this dude was like give me
uh it was like give me a [__] car I'm
like you got it bro
that was it yeah
and he just wanted a vehicle yeah oh
damn
that's like yeah that's one way to order
Uber right there bro damn that's [__]
gangster and you actually get in front
of it but the thing is he didn't even
know how much gas I got and be watching
this goofy I didn't even have no gas in
the car so you have to stop and get gas
stupid ass that's the law man
I need an oil change too oh so that's
what says sometimes you can take on
people's problems and you don't know
what's really in under the hood right
you want to take on somebody's life but
you don't know some of them that's like
taking somebody girl you texting my girl
don't even know what the [__] wrong with
her and you got a lot of [__] to deal
with yo yo yo your lip on the podcast
well that's your mic yeah but it's just
I feel that man sometimes you want
somebody's girl and you get or you
really even have to talk to her for five
minutes you're like damn somebody we got
to let this [__] go back you know that
happens a lot when you plug rock paper
scissors what do you usually pick like
rock papers or scissors
um average
I'll go scissors I think all right bro
let's play all right
they say scissors yeah but I switched it
up oh
let me ask you this man what else do you
so you get to Atlanta right you get to
Atlanta do you start to meet some of
your idols and heroes and stuff like
that must have been pretty good you know
I just met Kevin Hartley yesterday oh
did you really I posted a picture yeah I
met him oh he's actually dope he
actually uh was cool as [__] and and I
had took a picture with him and I was
thinking about to take the picture and
leave but he's like man stay around talk
let's chill may I actually [__] with
your content you a funny dude and he he
was like get in the stand he's like man
you're not doing stand-up we [__]
waiting we get yeah he's like we [__]
waiting and he's like man get out like
you see you happy like drink and I'm
sitting there I put my arm around him I
got comfortable like usually like you
know what I'm saying yeah it was just
like damn man and I at this the first
time I did not know how to ask for a
picture and I'm like damn like because
so many people be both you get it where
you eating and people like hey yo I want
a picture you're like bro I'm [__]
eating how do you have the courage to
come around me and my family hey yo let
me get a picture like that [__] is bold
so even me talking to him after we
talked for like 43 minutes I did not
know I'm like [__] I want this picture
also I want to take it back to the hood
like this is a hood trophy yeah like and
I know like no matter what phone be [__]
I got a picture with Kevin Hart yeah
like right now if I'm not [__] I'm just
flexing with that I just said something
to deal with Kevin Hart I'm I'm breaking
movies and then guess what they all
coming I get that picture is a three
months worth of [__] right there damn
that's a lot yeah that's a big trade-off
and did um was he uh who was like a
first person you met like that because
Atlanta did you get to me too short you
met too short that was one I really
wanted to take a picture with and I was
at the airport and he passed away huh no
didn't he
can you look up too short deceased
I think he did pass away man I'm sorry
no that's sorry man no that's too tall
no he's still here praise God baby damn
you talking about Too Tall or was it the
White Version Too Short now maybe Ed
Jones I think was hitting the name was
too tall you get too short mixed with Ed
Jones and well he was too tall I think
Ed Too Tall Jones was he somebody
oh dude I got a white version Tupac Too
Short
um we got who is it a white version of
Tupac I would say we kind of had Mac
Miller yeah no I wouldn't I said let's
add two Tall Jones right there
and he's dead or not no he's alive oh
good man what they both good
Jackson Tennessee that's where he's from
um
who is yeah let's go let's do versions
who is the okay who is y'all's Chris
Farley bro who's Chris Farley again or
who is not y'alls who who do you think
is a black version of Chris Farley who's
Chris Chris Farley bring him up Tommy
Boy remember him
um
he was on Saturday Night Live with Chris
Rock who would be uh he might be too old
of a ref you want to know who he is no
he not uh oh boy off of Keenan and kale
what's Keenan
that was the one that lost why he don't
see in the Saturn alive I feel like them
too you get it you see it I can see he
being ours
what about that one uh where the guy
lives in the house it's a sitcom
and he always
uh I don't think it's like a Medea show
but it's like did Madea have a sitcom do
you know um yeah she had like uh Mr
Brown you got I don't know it's a lie
it's so many media guys yeah there was
always this one kind of character the
dad he wasn't real fat though he was a
little thick but who's y'all Will Smith
oh damn that's a good one bro
so they would probably have to be tall
it just worked at the same type of
energy probably neck and neck you can
line them up
um
that could be Matthew McConaughey bruh
who's on Nicki Minaj
Oh Lady Gaga
I don't know if she throws that hole
like Nikki does though
foreign
I don't know if we have one I think we
tried to have one with that girl uh
Iguodala oh no oh Iggy Iggy I think
that's her that was our attempt at
having a Nicki Minaj sometimes you don't
even get the same thing like Carrot Top
right they don't have I feel like they
don't really have like a black Carrot
Top
so how do you feel about Justin Bieber I
feel like he's so dope and he got all
type of code that's one guy that
marketed the [__] out of him we got
everybody to love him he did and just
stay out the way and stay clean he came
to a show of my man in New York actually
a few years ago he had been sick and he
liked funny [__] too yeah he does comedy
he does and he love you know you're
right he loves people it is something
when I see Justin uh and I see his
energy I feel inspired to love everybody
yeah that's what that's the best way to
do it like in angry people
it's crazy you know the people that just
hung their horn and get mad blinker get
over you're gonna be that same person I
want to get over and somebody gonna honk
at you so don't do what the [__] you
don't want done to you yeah well it's
easy it's easier said than done too but
I feel you you know yeah but um it was
cool he came out to a show they came out
he hadn't been out in a long time and
because he hadn't been he'd been sick
and him and Carl Lentz who was a pastor
that came out to my comedy show in New
York and I didn't even get to see him
they came and they left a gift for me in
the Green Room
and they stayed for about maybe a half
of the show and Carl said that Justin
wasn't feeling good and so they left
what r b do you listen to
um let me see I I like to listen to
um
let me think about what I would call
thinking like who who was it like a pop
like artist when I was growing up I used
to listen to Tevin Campbell's
can we talk for a minute
and then uh I mean I'll listen to like
the you know a lot of the regular guys
Michael Jackson but then I got in a rap
and I listened to like um
a lot of like uh Lil Wayne Cash Money uh
mystical speaking of Louisiana I feel
like you and Kevin Gates would go at it
just kind of like awkward conversation
for awkward conversation it could be I
would like to see Kevin Gates you know
he's kind of a wildcat he kind of got
that Native American you know he's got
some real roots in him he did that Kayla
Presley show yeah I could see him y'all
y'all gotta y'all gotta make that happen
Kevin Gates
um what about uh you what are some of
your other goals so obviously you have
this unique ability to kind of create a
different angle of looking at things
that's what I feel like if one of your
strong suits to me it's like this is a
different this humor so huh it's a third
eye bet yeah you got a third eye so ha
so do you want to like make movie what
do you want to do dude are you already
doing everything you want working on
movies uh that's why I came down here to
get that done stand up I go on tour uh
we're going to Minnesota I'm with Desi
Banks I'm at the time he got to come on
your show uh we're going on tour with
him
and you like I said you inspired me
there's this apartment Kmart this was
the run like I really need getting to
stand up and even watching your [__] you
don't give a [__] and when you're on
stage and you don't get [__] it makes
them laugh more my thing was focusing on
the crowd and goes back to where I told
you when that lady spent 13 000 I so
focus on I want them happy they spent
their money because people complain if
they don't they don't get their food
right they complain they don't get their
shirt right so when people spend their
money they complain even when [__] is
free they still complain yeah I can't
worry about that though I gotta do me
and do on that stage and at the end of
the day just know it's gonna be
complainers and lovers so I was so
worried about the negative side that's
what I said people worry about nothing
you forget about the positive I'm like
[__] it's a half and half and your whole
goal was to just get everybody in that
room on the same page because it comes
back to what we said earlier this is my
closet so if I open this [__] you in
here just know this is all my wardrobe
this is all me
well I think also people getting to know
you a little bit more even just as a
human that makes them even be more
understanding this is what I've found
right if I make mistakes if I'm learning
about something if I'm thinking about
something if I'm learning how to be
honest about talking about uh any
thoughts I have about race stuff
anything like that if I'm people will
ride with you as long as you're trying
to be true to whatever you are if you
make mistakes or not most people will
ride with you as a human you know like
it's you know because there's more to
you know people love the humor but then
also they get to know the person you
know there's a lot of artists out there
that people start to love the person you
know it's interesting it's almost like
they supersede their own talent because
people are like oh I'll watch them
almost in anything they do because
they're just something about them that I
really like and sometimes people gotta
know when life's Camera Action some
people just shop for cameras and they
ain't even know who they are so people
will try to be like oh this and that and
he shouldn't have said that and it's
like he just [__] sit down camera
because he ain't said that day in his
[__] life so but like I said you're
gonna live in what you say nowadays but
I know I feel like back in the day when
you used to do [__] they didn't give a
[__] without social there's a lot of
[__] going on and people didn't give a
[__] because
you know I'm not putting energy in to
pay attention to it but now you can
scroll and see 5 000 comments like oh
let me say something too it's like
jumping people it's like one person say
something it's like let's jump this
[__] yeah so it's just kind of
like you're gonna get jumped in the
comments and it's just like they might
even mean that you know what I'm saying
so that's what I said you gotta watch
what you say in like even with you know
people that getting on me are probably
watching this part I've been I did that
podcast uh uh the dudes at the table uh
fresh and fit have you seen that [__] I
did it before uh you never seen this
[__] before I haven't oh yeah
you gotta look up the it's a good pull
up a piece of it Zachary
get that fresh and fit huh it's also but
they this is what they say it's a bunch
of loser guys that can't get girls and
they listen to two guys and they just
bring girls on the show to bash them
but I mean it's I don't know what to
call it like oh dang that seems is it
kind of cold uh
it's funny moments on there but like I
said it's just how you I'm not a
sensitive person like if you're not
comfortable on the show [__] leave if
you like me I already put up a fight if
you feel like the bad [__] be
[__] with them but like I'm a Metro
energy and I'm embarrassing you like you
trying to embarrass me so where do you
see you have a lot of good like kind of
theories on your own behavior and ways
to like kind of navigate yourself where
does some of that come from for you uh
that's funny actually just getting lack
of attention as a child and just being
the one that's kind of last so we've
been counting last and always been a
bottom is like what the [__] can I do to
get to the top and when I get to the top
I always remember when I was last so now
I'm here keep both of those energy you
keep that [__] equal so that's why I
just like don't go overboard don't go
underboard because at the end of the day
it's gonna be people that was in my spot
I want them to know we can get up here
and be okay
um it's like did you have were you did
y'all have a lot of children your folks
yeah you got a lot of kids yeah my mama
got four kids uh
it was just her she got yes four kids
she got four different baby daddies oh
she's not a whole but it's like I mean
in the hood that technically make you a
hoe she did it but she had a kid each
year sorry man but then she had a kid
each year so she like [__] on one
person each year right so I was like
that's gross these days that's great
yeah
I think a year yeah
that's good yeah but when you look at it
it looked like she just was [__]
right yeah and that's yeah that's why
she should carry a little car with her
and show people how it broke down yeah
exactly or wear a shirt get a shirt mate
yeah it had the dates on it yeah like
2002 like how they win the championship
yeah Randy Wendell yeah yeah Brady yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah that should be though
that's crazy yeah we had four my mom had
four kids too man you was your mama ho
too yeah uh my mom actually dated a
black guy when I was growing up she
dated a black Jewish guy does he like
him yeah he was interesting we didn't
you know we didn't know she didn't
accept until she didn't let introduce
y'all to her oh she did he came around
he was interesting he was really like
you said he shot snacks and [__] oh he
didn't try to touch me or anything no
each other not that y'all get your food
snacks and [__] your food no no no he's
like I think so when we run like snacks
is like art our candy our [__] our
snacks chips like I'm step daddy that
type of snacks okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think yeah I love black people love
chips I noticed that's one thing that's
safe that's that's yeah that's a few
little chips yeah yeah
uh but this man no Mom didn't he was
nice I didn't know he taught us some
different stuff oh he bought us tickets
to the first football game ever won oh
he wanted to go so he just took y'all
yeah he just actually they just dropped
us off so they might have went to [__]
honestly oh yeah yeah damn I didn't even
think about that I mean honestly I mean
he paid for it her because he paid for
y'all to get the tickets to get that is
yeah look it was nice of him it's a
business transaction but it was
interesting man I'm trying to think yeah
when I was growing up they had what do
you feel about Triple H
the
wrestler wrestler yeah
I think I maybe I don't have a big
thought on him my favorite wrestler
probably was uh
I like Undertaker
yeah he was good there's so many
versions of him Last Ride the Dead one
it's so many I'm so [__] up about Kane
I don't know what happened he came out
cool and then he just got fat and sloppy
it was like what the [__] happened to
Kane yeah I think he may he could have
had some medical issues or some of those
guys I don't think it was the same
person they oh you think they switched
him
damn remember he was fit yeah
bring up a cane if you can Zachary uh
the king years if you can bring up all
the 18 years did you know who uh
the craziest thing I ever saw was at the
when the rock came back I was at WWE
right
and Mexican people love
wrestling bro I saw a Father and Son bro
they didn't know The Rock was coming
back and they like and he came running
out and they both started bawling crying
brother yeah the rock is remember that
baby when he met just he post on his
page yeah he he [__] yeah the rock is
a [__] genius and dope it's funny
like it was dope he actually followed me
I was like damn did he really yeah he
followed me so damn bro like damn The
Rock like actually said and like damn
that [__] dope like isn't it crazy to
realize sometimes when you see people
certain people that follow you like
that's kind of they look up to you like
now like your content or just that they
even know who you are bro that like if
they saw you somewhere they would come
up and say something that's crazy well
the hardest part is when they know you
you still got to keep being known for
that and be fresh and stay clean that's
gonna be like yeah well I used to put
like you know what I'm saying that's why
you got to watch as you say watch what
you do and just treat everybody with
respect and if you feel some type of way
share with your best friend that's why
you got a best friend Aries secret ain't
meant to be told on the internet so if
you feel some keep that [__] to yourself
like
that [__] you know what I'm saying now
that you can't tell your girlfriend they
break up and then they hate you but tell
your brother or some [__] but nowadays
you can't because they get money
nowadays just don't say [__] honestly
leave it for me keep the [__] to
yourself yeah get in the shower and just
talk to yourself
do you think uh was your were any of
your siblings really funny too did y'all
have yeah we had a funny family like
y'all did yeah we we had a funny
dysfunctional family yeah
that's [__] I got a brother that like
check on me like yo what you doing like
I love a new video uh what's the next
one I tell them you're like yo can I
have five thousand dollars and it's like
he lead me right into that punch anyway
yo congratulations bro like that love
the video what do you win the next
interview then I tell him about yo you
got 500 to send me so it's like he
always smacked me with this thing where
it just kind of like they hit you with
that love punch like bro like don't just
ask for the [__] money and don't I
hate when family ask for money to borrow
and they not gonna pay you back yeah
vara's the worst word yeah yeah isn't it
crazy like uh is it crazy to look at
your own life and be like wow this
really is my life sometime
I like to play the game I don't like
clubbing I don't like smoking or
drinking I like to laugh I like to look
at awkward [__] make [__] awkward yeah
like you don't say the whole podcast
where it was awkward funny but some
people probably look at it like they're
gonna probably say [__] about you say
[__] about me but I have a third eye
like this [__] was actually funny laugh
and [__] go to sleep like at the end
of the day I I like you know my favorite
movie is uh
super bad it was just about a lot of
weird funny [__]
do they have a good
you know what it is interesting like do
they have a black version of Superbike
Friday I say like Friday After Next that
would be kind of like our hit uh you got
uh bad boys too like was kind of like
comedy but just a bunch of high school
kids no we ain't got they kind of need
that version that shit's missing isn't
it that's something that's missing we
need to uh step in our culture and
actually be together and start doing
projects with us we can't do that like
and it sometimes it takes people ego
that feels like I built my platform I
don't want to share it like you know but
we need that everybody need it for their
culture oh that's one thing I noticed
about Joe that's one thing that Joe
Rogan does really well that dude shares
his platform yeah he sure he put I mean
whoever he'll put the smallest dude or
the biggest dude you know he puts he
puts people on you know that's always
one thing that I really admire about him
I'm here you know if you ever can I do
an interview with him yeah yeah that'd
be cool I'll recommend you uh I will
I'll throw that in his ear that'd be
really interesting he's gonna be crazy
if you said it and then don't do it
that'd be dope
well here's what you know what I'll do
I'll send uh some of his stuff some of
your stuff to him well you got to get
this guy on there yeah or you can say
like yo we did a podcast this guy's is
kind of like a [__] groupie bro do
something with them bro and then I'll
pay you and then you if he say no you
can [__] around uh take five thousand
dollars transferred into like my bank
account yeah and then send me up your
social security number your debit card
front and back this is not a scam might
sound like it but keep up with me okay
you send me your route number to your
bank account all right running back uh
transfer the funds and then just send me
credit card [__] you will be blocked
I'ma block you but that's part of the
progress don't freak out don't say oh
what the [__] it's getting nervous yeah
I will come back in a year or so and
I'll pay you back and you're gonna email
me right yeah
all right yeah we can do that that
checks out trust me yeah as long as you
email me what I'll do is wait by the
email yeah just wait by the email like
and that's what I said just that's how
the thing goes so my God and then it's
basically like making 50 000 into a
hundred thousand so if you want fifty
thousand to a hundred thousand you give
me the fifty and then it's gonna take
probably two or three weeks yeah because
wow because why but
um wires or something no I'm busy I'm
sorry I'm busy with the money let me do
my thing okay and then you end up you
know what I'm saying you're gonna send
me that and then you just say what's
going on give me three don't bother me
while I'm doing it if you do you'll get
blocked but that's part of like you
freaking out you will block you and
don't be nervous probably then huh yeah
yeah but you'll freak out but I'm
telling you now that's part of the
progress so you shouldn't be nervous
like I tell my wife or not don't tell
her don't let nobody know because it's
our business yeah and that's when
somebody like dude you just got [__]
scam but you didn't because I'm telling
you everything now and it's actually
recorded yeah so it'll go back to like
let me follow the steps you will get
blocked and then that's when after that
I'll follow you with an email and I'm
saying this me just relax so you're
gonna get the email all right and then
after that you will get another uh
a transfer I'ma send you a thousand just
to tell you just be happy okay
yeah that's a wire and so what so I just
wait by the email yeah I'll be back to
three to four years with a hundred
thousand okay it's an investment
yeah man I think I think we should do it
I think I'm in yeah I'm not going to
tell her I'm not going to tell her
anything tell me about this bro
a lot of black people are flat earthers
you ever meet these dudes well just flat
over me dudes I think the Earth is flat
not round
um see honestly there are a lot of
people saying that [__] uh but the first
dude I ever met rolled up on me in a
pizza joint two two black guys they said
hey man
darf is flat I don't know like certain
[__]
I don't know because I don't really look
into like certain [__] like that I need
to start looking into like just what
this [__] is do black people like outer
space or not
nameless Craig I'm pretty sure some
people out there I'm just not looking
into it like I'm too busy looking at two
[__] kangaroos to see how they [__]
yeah that's why I watch on my YouTube
history oh yeah yeah so I can look into
that but right now I wouldn't have the
answer for it and I wouldn't lie black
people a lot of black men are good at
sex I feel like that's a generalization
would you say that yeah sex symbols do
they well I wouldn't know because I
haven't had sex with a like uh or any
type of guy okay
but if you know speaking from women yeah
point of view yeah they say that and I
heard some girls say like white doesn't
put it down two really yeah okay so
there's some white guys that can do it
and there's a lot of black guys that can
do it okay that's as that's even it's
even you think so I feel like a lot of
[__] even it's just certain people don't
want to hear some of the stereotypes
yeah but here's what I'm saying do I
feel like but do do you ever look at
animals [__] and think oh I wanna I
could do that yeah that's why I'm gonna
be a snapping turtle I want to see how
Turtles [__] oh man bro yeah I mean you
listening to Eddie Levert yeah that's
gotta be slow uh before we go I want to
say that I feel like sometimes girls do
commit suicide because there's no way
they should give hit by cardiac so
[__] fast so when the squirrel get in
the street and you actually hit one it
was it was ready to go damn
because then sometimes they get fed up
too
oh
yeah man I guess I feel so bad I just
get stuck in my own world a lot and I'm
not even thinking about that yeah
but that's big facts man yeah RP to the
squirrels here all right people I wonder
if uh animals have baby showers and [__]
you think they should yeah I'm sure they
do in the woods people roll up bring a
little treat yeah
yeah it is almost kind of beautiful huh
[__] baby sea lion baby shower
oh dude I imagine too a [__] little
penguin putting lotion on his buddy like
that yeah
so congratulations bro
and he's like yeah I'm gonna see if it's
mine first we're gonna take a blood test
because she been [__] on Chad Chad is
the other penguin oh yeah they'll just
[__] on everybody because he's a sex
symbol
yeah but he just for now he's just
supporting his buddy yeah
thanks man
funny Marco man I appreciate you so much
coming to spending time bro no I
appreciate you this uh this is dope uh I
just want the world to know that I feel
your energy I feel like you for
everybody like you are actually a good
guy thanks man yeah
it's like sometimes we got our little
duvalls that just speak their money you
got you that speak your mind so it's
kind of like put me in the color that
speak my mind and don't try to make me
seem like I'm talking to anybody because
I'm just I'm just mean I speak my mind
so anybody can get it at this point so
you like a uh
yeah hardcore match remember anything
goes on in that [__] yeah it's not
handicapped because you don't want to
just attack anytime it's hardcore like
Scarface I'm going out like a soldier
[__] you [__] you you [__] you you
you're cool you're cool you're cool
you're cool [__] you that's what I feel
like you are yeah
thanks man I appreciate it I'm trying to
be you know I try to let go of whatever
little Hang-Ups I have here and there
sometimes you know because some of it's
just things that are from the past and
they sometimes still grippy here or
there you get little edges you know you
gotta round them and sometimes life just
it takes time you know some of it but
yeah I feel like life's been getting
better and I want to be able to be kind
of uh yeah I want to be able to have
like a universe as much as a universal
audience as you can you know sometimes
you can't even pick your own audience
you know yeah but yeah I think so many
people love you man I mentioned your
name last night I was talking young
grave he was just here he's a rapper he
was here
um and then I was talking to some of the
nelt guys last night they don't love you
like [__] with them man yeah you got so
many fans it's cool so I feel real
grateful for your time man yeah no I
appreciate you having me here so at the
end of the day it's all about history
what we leave behind because between me
you one of us is gonna die first I don't
see us dying at the same time like we
both getting to try and it's like damn
they both down the same day so somebody
gotta go first and we'd be able to go
back and watch this [__] yeah yeah and
they probably go you probably go first
though
I feel like okay sometimes I start
feeling hardcore bro like you're [__]
yeah you're like a Hellcat yeah
[__] Hellcat Scat Pack bro he's out
here and so what happens to me
uh and be honest with me I see you
probably just
bleed out no I'm not bleeding nothing to
do with that just you just kind of like
sit there and you just think like what
the [__] am I about to do and then
you're going there you go in there you
go do it turn around turn back around
see it and you like [__] that's my
calling then you think about it and you
say what the [__] what's next wait a
minute I need to get some [__] first
you go get the [__] yeah you [__] it up
two minutes because you said that's how
long you last hey I'm busy though that's
all you need you turn around get in the
bed and you say oh [__] you know what I
forgot my [__] cell phone I can't go
without it cause I gotta take some
[__] while I'm up there get the cell
phone and then you go to the bank you
got to get some money because you stay
you got to put something out you don't
like swiping you gotta have cash on you
you're always like that if I'm gonna see
the [__] I might have to have some
loot right so you get the cash you go
and eat like [__] if I get up there and
I got a problem with anybody I gotta get
me a shotgun you go buy your shotgun oh
yeah you're taking that up there with
you or borrow one too exactly somebody
somebody gonna have one yeah
and then that's when you just go to
sleep
um
and they don't really know what happened
but it happened
damn bro I love it predicting the future
baby yeah funny Marco man thank you so
much for your time bro I really do
appreciate it and I'll see you in the
future bro if you stay alive man yeah
I'm gonna be praying that's funny we
should start saying that to people
imagine somebody like all right man see
you later if you say it alive like
that's it that's just a normal sale I'm
gonna say that to my Uber I'm like
yeah right because they might think man
what did that do no bro especially now
because people aren't even talking to
each other anymore so if you say hey man
I'll see you in the future if you stay
alive yeah yeah boy is it [__] the
future it's like bro like I'll call you
tomorrow if you stay alive yeah bro yeah
and it puts pressure on a [__]
now their life means something yeah now
they're like all right bro I better
[__] lace these shoes up baby because
obviously somebody got me on the clock
man yeah that's funny bro see me learn
something right at the ear I know if you
stay alive let's say you should start
merch right there if you stay alive can
you start this one here y'all yeah merch
shirts bro can you start them if you
stay alive if you stay alive because
that's all it takes see you tomorrow if
you stay alive yeah I'll see you
tomorrow right there right there sell
those shirts y'all please bomb for me
and just put you know wearing for me bro
see you tomorrow if you stay alive sell
out please buy his merch praise thanks
Marco let's get it appreciate y'all now
[Music]
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share
our shelves
[Music]
gonna take